our other top story tonight it is
something that might seem harmless
throwing eggs at a house or a car as a
joke but for many in the northwest
valley it's becoming a real problem
reports of somebody driving by and
egging people's cars in a neighborhood
near ann road and durango causing damage
and just a lot of headaches sasha loftus
joining us now live tonight with more
denise and brian when most of us see an
egg like this we think of food maybe a
breakfast dish but dish but they can
also be used as tools to destroy
property i spoke with one man tonight
who experienced that firsthand
here got hit with one egg leo moreno
shares his frustration with a unique
form of vandalism in his northwest
valley neighborhood just driving around
and hitting everybody's car is not it's
not cool his car and a handful of others
egged by someone driving up and down his
street at night you can see the guy
throwing that one car and eggs flying in
to the other vehicle something like this
may seem like a harmless prank but
victor botneri of universal motor cars
tells me it can actually cause a lot of
damage eggs contain
sulfur which is acidic depending on when
and where it happens repairs could cost
hundreds or even thousands of dollars it
makes an indentation in the panel
second thing if it's not cleaned right
away that the sulfur the acid goes into
the clear coat and the paint and damages
the paint leo says he was lucky to catch
this mess and clean it right away but if
you look around there's still a couple
little egg shells on the ground but he
hopes those behind this will think twice
before they target this area again
everybody is on the watch out for them
so somebody's going to catch him
now if you have had your car or your
house egged you can file a report with
metro police now victor also suggested
double checking your insurance policy
and seeing if you have a zero deductible
for any kind of vandalism that'll make
sure that your insurance covers any sort
of damage from a situation like this
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now